we've been trained since kindergarten in
our government schools to regard the
media as authoritative and as you know
hard-working people fighting for the
little guy and trying to present the
truth yet we see many many examples of
the little guy Nicholas Sandman is a
very obvious example those cadets who
were playing the circle game the gun
here's an easy example the guy who
photoshopped CNN into that gif with
Trump wrestling them CNN said we reserve
the right to sue you
yeah that's not to hunt him down destroy
him for creating a meme that's not
looking out for the little guy that's
looking up for number one this is the
Rubin report and according to a Russian
bot farm I'm Dave Rubin quick reminder
guys to subscribe to our YouTube channel
which gives you a 5% chance of actually
seeing our videos in the feed pretty
good joining me today is the author of
the new right the host of the you're
welcome podcast and the man that I've
dubbed the Willy Wonka politics
Michael malice welcome back to the Rubin
report thanks so much
well sir where to start I think your
outfit yeah it reminds me of somebody a
former guest I didn't see you until two
minutes ago you walked in here wearing
this gorgeous little thing yeah I've
been known for this look for years is
that right all of a sudden I get phone
calls who's this woman
tulsi who's been dressing like you she's
so nuts she even put a streak in her
hair to pass as me even more and I
looked this up she says she's from this
state called Hawaii white I never heard
this there's a bunch of volcanoes in the
middle of the Atlantic and we're
supposed to believe that this is a state
they live in volcanoes rain of liquid
metal that they check the weather and
this is people this is how they
gerrymander the electoral college and
now they're trying to say Graham's
estate when I asked my friend where's
Graham find to me on the map he points
this little island by the boot that's
Sicily you saying Graham Graham Graham
have you ever found they're making up
words I think in them states that this
is how the fake news media gets over it
anyway getting back to her campaign I
think she's great
yes I've been following her very closely
and I think it's reprehensible what's
being done to people like Chelsea
the congressman from so-called Hawaii
and all the other Democratic outliers
this is a wonderful change in our
politics where so many people are
realizing the nature of the enemy all
right so we're gonna talk about all of
that stuff but because a huge portion of
our people just listen to audio I do
feel that I have to describe where
you're wearing honky you are in a white
Leisure Suit it's a suit this is a
business a leisure suit it seems like a
leisure so you look like Leisure Suit
Larry or you look like Larry from
Three's Company or something like that
or we can do the Don Johnson or John
Travolta suit but you are know this is
very much the tulsi gabbard white zone
this is the Michael malleus look that
tells that he'll see appropriate yes yes
yes no okay so you you get a whole bunch
of stuff there the reason that I wanted
to have you back because as you know I
find you to be one of the most
interesting political thinkers out there
I do
thank there you go paying you a
compliment right affront you you
consistently strike me as someone that
is always like really on what I would
say is the forward fringe of what's
happening culturally and politically in
the whole shebang so let's let's start
where you just started there that there
suddenly seems to be a couple outliers
with the Dems and the DNC or the powers
that be or the gatekeepers or the New
York Times or CNN or whatever else you
want to call that not too happy yeah for
a long time conservatives often get
things wrong and I criticize them very
heavily on my Twitter and when I speak
of them I do so with great love and
affection they have always argued that
the media is a wing of the DNC and what
we're seeing recently now is it's more
accurate to say that the DNC is a wing
of the media because you'll see things
like anyone who deviates as you
mentioned earlier from basically the
media's party line is crushed let's
let's give an example I'm a Democratic
congressman right let's suppose from
Hawaii or some other or some other day
that we exist yes and for three years my
constituents have heard CNN and MSNBC
talk about Russia collusion Russia
collusion trumps Hitler Trump's this
from snap how am i as a politician
supposed to go back to my constituents
and say with a straight face
I think Trump's the worst president ever
I think he's racist concentration camps
you know despicable he's ruined the
presidency but I don't think this is
grounds for removing him from office and
I don't have that space so it's pretty
clear who's the one who was leading the
charge and who was following it and for
a long time again conservative thought
this was Republican versus Democrat and
now we're seeing that his establishment
versus outsider because we're seeing it
how they treated Tulsi we're seeing it
how they treated Bernie and Andrew yang
that's the special one because Andrew
Yang is hardly some wide-eyed radical
right he's a wonk
he's in many ways akin to Mitt Romney
you know in certain ways he wears the
math lapel pin he wants people to
succeed yeah he said he's a business guy
and mostly a centrist right probably or
not probably certainly way too big
government for you right sure
but at least you think he's a sort of
functional human being and doesn't come
out of the machine right and he is there
have been many cases where he's
basically been treated as if he doesn't
exist they used the wrong photo for him
he tweeted out that every other campaign
gets to have people who represent them
on your shows but with him it has to be
him personally so when people on the
Left are starting to realize oh this
isn't about Republican versus Democrat
this is about us versus them and you can
just as easily be a Democrat and be our
them eyes are opening and that is a very
very healthy phenomenon I always say
that the corporate press is the enemy of
the people and I think that's the
moderate position what is the corporate
press really like what is the
psychological makeup of the corporate
press that causes this whole thing sure
so basically what you have are the
universities and that's where the evil
starts and we've been trained since
kindergarten in our government schools
to regard the media as authoritative and
as you know hard-working people fighting
for the little guy and trying to present
the truth yet we see many many examples
of the little guy Nicholas Sandman is a
very obvious example those cadets who
were playing the circle game the gut
here's an easy example the guy who
photoshopped CNN into that gif with
Trump wrestling them CNN said we reserve
the right to sue you yeah that's not to
hunt him down destroy him for creating a
meme that's not looking out for the
little guy that's looking
for number one do you know I've asked a
bunch of guesses but do you think
there's a moment where something changed
because it wasn't always this hard I get
it's being exposed now more because
because we can all immediately tweet out
the truth the second you know they they
pump out the lie but do you think there
was some other seminal moments somewhere
along the road was it always this
horrible and this is what conservatives
don't appreciate we all learn in high
school about William Randolph Hearst the
spanish-american war remember the Maine
and yellow journalism and then they just
kind of the record scratch and now we're
into today I have a big thread on
Twitter
Walter Durante's at the prime example he
was a New York Times man covering the
Soviet Union and while Stalin
intentionally committed a genocide via
starvation of Ukraine the holiday more
he was putting out dispatches all the
time saying there's no problem if there
is a problem it is malevolent propaganda
he said the Russian people out it's a
little tough but they're tightening
their belts tighten their belts is a
very interesting idiom in this context
and what they what Stalin did to these
people is if you were a Kulak which
meant landowner but pretty soon man
anyone if you had any food in your home
that was for the people they ransacked
her house and took it and if you weren't
starving that's how they knew you were
hiding food and that's who they targeted
so they would beat people mercilessly
they would tear their house upside down
kick him out in the streets you know to
starve and there was another reporter
who and going to this area was forbidden
by the Soviet government there was a
reporter who jumped off the train went
to a few villages reported back what was
happening these Horrors and Durante was
like oh you know he's just an anti
Soviet agitator so this has been going
on for a very long time
they've always been hardcore I call them
jihadis without the testosterone they
have been very demented idea ideology
that will do everything in its power to
maintain its hold on power and only now
that they've been that check in real
time and called out on their tactics in
real time are people realizing oh I'm
just gonna say my point it's not cod
this to yesterday I said it's not about
the corruption it's about the depravity
if it was just hey I'm hiring my brother
and he's getting paid too much money sin
has asked no
care yeah right they know they do that
that's fine that's what this is about
amy robach and Jeffrey Epstein when you
have a network that knows that someone
is engaged in the sexual trade of
children and their concern is not
getting an interview with Meghan Markel
and when this is exposed instead of
coming clean it's let's target the
person who revealed this footage and get
them fired at the network which they
went to it's a lot it's a lot it's a lot
but what do you think about the sort of
psychological condition of these people
like when I watch all of these clips of
CNN anchors saying the reverse of the
truth or Cuomo tweeting out that you
know look at the way the right attacks
Greta Thunderbird when he went after
Nick Sandman or just oh you know a kid
and all of this nonsense that they never
stop they seem completely
psychologically unable to stop and that
strikes me is very weird you know I sit
with a lot of people if you were to say
something to me that was patently true
that was against what I believe I would
struggle with it I would we would work
it through I would ask you some
questions but I know myself I would
probably change my mind if you made a
compelling case we now are at a point
where there's a lot of compelling
evidence that these people lie endlessly
and nothing ever stops them I I don't
even know that I would use the word lie
and here's why I talk about this heavily
in the book I regard what I call the
evangelical left these types when you're
a here n't to a fundamentalist Creed
facts do not change your opinion in fact
contradictory facts maybe that are down
right so if you are talking to someone
who is a hardcore creationist and you
show them fossils they're not going to
wonder if creations was wrong they will
regard this as evidence that their
willpower and faith is correct and this
is just the test and it's the exact same
psychology the contemporary and I don't
regard all leftists in this vein I
regard this specifically as these jihadi
types they have this vision that they
are the ones who are going to save
America in the world and it's a
degeneration of what happened 100 years
ago called the social gospel which was
the premise that instead of an
individual being saved which is a basic
premise of Christianity it's the nation
be saved however when you have this
worldview that a nation's soul can be
saved or the earth soul can be saved
that means there is no space that is
outside your purview that means whatever
someone watches whatever someone does at
home
anything aspect of your life is subject
to their domination and control so it is
an absolute totalitarian worldview and
they admit it they you know other than
may perhaps abortion if you ask them
what is a place where it's not your
place to judge they will just kind of
their eyes will shake yeah well there
Thanos right I mean this is what I keep
saying every week now Venice was
successful but but they might be
successful they're gonna have to kill a
lot of people to do it right uh you know
Rand Iran was on Donahue and I've seen
the quick a million times yeah
and he asked her why you so hard in
these people why don't you you know just
say I disagree and she goes because I
look at them they don't hesitate to
sacrifice entire nations so the people
who like advocated for Venezuela you
know and the horrors that are going on
there I mean you know I yeah
your animals being eaten you know kids
lying in pools of blood because you
don't have hospital supplies during
childbirth no one who pushed for this
was like wow I made a huge mr. bear's
you gotta keep going cuz because
otherwise you have to turn it on
yourself right and there's never any
accountability Julian Reed who allegedly
by her own words called the FBI about
tweets that she sent out is still
gainfully employed and the day after
this brouhaha between Bernie Sanders and
Elizabeth Warren where if Bernie had
said I don't think a woman can be
elected they are portraying it as him
saying I don't think a woman should sure
yeah yeah she has a huge distinction
that everybody just like ran shot across
and intentionally muddled yeah she had a
body language expert on just show that
Bernie's like and he was the amazing
part the body language actress like when
he was asked this question he shrunk and
got nervous
he's on national television being told
being asked to say is his good friend
lying about him who's not going to get
nervous so when you watch a moment like
that the the you know can a woman be
elected moment between the two of them
and then suddenly the audio leaks right
after and Elizabeth Warren walks up to
him and says you know you just called me
a liar when you see the
do you think that the entire thing is
staged because that struck me as
Elizabeth Warren somehow coordinated
something with CNN so that she knew the
mics were on and she could just get a
little more juice because they really do
hate Bernina I despise all of Bernie's
ideas I think all of them we'll get into
that a little bit but I would say 90% of
them probably but we'll do that that she
though coordinated something that
something felt really off about that
like oh this is just where they happen
to have left the mics on you know what
it's like to have a mic on and be
wandering around and the amount of stuff
that gets dropped so I won things I
talked heavily in my work and then you
write is the concept of the red pill and
for those who don't know the red pills
from the movie from the documentary The
Matrix and once you're a red pill that
is the understanding that what we see is
presented as truth in the corporate
press is in fact a carefully constructed
narrative designed to keep some very
unpleasant people in power so a lot of
people are trained to think of a
television screen as a window right so
when you're doing what you're doing
that's a red pilling like wait a minute
what's the backstory that is leading me
to see what's happening here if I had to
guess I would guess she just didn't care
one way or another that she was that he
probably did say something similar but
in knock you say hey do you think a
woman get elected and obviously women
are going to have an uphill battle it's
never happened before and she's
portraying it and as you know I'll you
know poor victim me and she just wanted
to confront him to look tough on the
record I think she genuinely felt she
does not handle a counter punch very
well the best thing the best Elizabeth
Warren is not a dummy she taught at
Harvard she's a bright woman you know
what I mean and that's so sure teaching
at Harvard makes one break it's I mean
you forget how smart the average person
is so yeah I'm going back so you have
her with it with Trump for a year take
the DNA test take the DNA taste take the
edenia DNA test she takes it and she
goes there I took it he goes who cares
so he broke this woman's brain and on
some level I feel a little bit bad for
her but I don't but the beauty of social
media is after that exchange happened
all her tweets are being bombed with
snake snake emoji realize by Sanders
supporters and now he
taken all her support so let's talk
about that a little bit cuz what I think
you really are sort of an expert at is
like the Internet the underbelly of the
internet side of this so when you see a
moment like that you know
the Sanders Warren thing and then
literally it was just thousands and
thousands of people whether you're like
troll left rolling or not but it was
right it was lefties
well I find the Bernie people now I'm
critical of Bernie obviously especially
on Twitter I find the Bernie people to
be the most unbearable on Twitter the
the most hostile and nine and it's weird
because they have you know that most of
them have roses in their emojis and they
have their gender pronouns and
everything's about diversity and
tolerance but I find them to to be the
worst but they really turned on her but
when you see a moment like that and then
you see the people who the snakes come
in and all the fighting after that you
that's like your game right like you who
loves that warning yeah like anytime you
have this conflict and strife it's
beautiful it's very healthy I'm very
much for as much political division as
possible I think when the parties get
together or when one party gets together
you have things that are generous
abominations like Obamacare or you know
more this is what happens when the two
gangs you know drop their arms and
decide to shake hands so do you think if
we just had sort of an endless internal
battle within the parties so they could
sort of not really do anything because
they'd just be internally fighting that
that would put us in a better political
situation because really not much could
happen yeah and I think it's gonna lead
eventually to kind of the breakup of the
United States because this country has
been United with basically thumbtacks
and strings since the beginning and
there's no reason for two or more
cultures who have increasing contempt
and an inability to speak to each other
to be part of one polity was this the
inevitable conclusion do you think of
the melting pot because it's worked here
better than it's worked anywhere else do
you think that's a fair I don't think
it's because the melting I mean look at
the Civil War I mean this has been from
the beginning I mean you had what at the
very beginning it was the North that
wanted to secede because they I mean
culturally they're very opposed and
actually before the melting pot the
argument was well we're the anglo-saxons
in the north and they're Teutonic or
Scottish whatever I remember they were
honest but we got through all of it I
mean we had a civil war and then we
became a united nation we didn't because
the South was regarded as the
subordinate conquered land whipping-boy
and to this day you know people just we
just saw that in CNN
people just regard the south as this
kind of degenerate version of the rest
of the United States sure I'm not saying
there aren't elites and people that mock
each other and all that but we have one
functional country and you can travel to
the south and travel to the north to do
Commerce and all of those things like I
get it I'm not saying there aren't
engines and all that but even within
that we've still remained basically
peaceful sure and I think that I think
one of the big misconceptions and this
is another idea is that if there's going
to be any segregation separation or
segregation self-segregation it has to
be violent and a great counter example
this is brexit you know Britain's
leaving that you they're doing it it's
going to be a tough it's gonna be a long
divorce but they're doing it peacefully
so there's I think increasingly there is
an understanding that there's no need
and social media is speeding this up
it's causing people to go to their
logical extremes in terms of politics
and there's left less room in the middle
which is exactly what I like because I
think when you're in the middle that
means you don't really have any
principles so if this thing gets to what
I guess you would say is its inevitable
conclusion that was I'm hoping that's
what I'm pushing it oh you don't think
it's inevitable okay so if it gets to
the conclusion that Michel analyses
neither what is that freedom it's not
having you know the biggest government
on earth you know taking all this money
out of you you know obviously the
ultimate conclusion would hopefully be
an anarchist system but we've got a long
way to go to tear down this Goliath
that's been built up over centuries and
I think it's wonderful that Trump and
the Democrats are both bringing such
disdain and disrepute to the electoral
system and democracy in general is that
the ultimate flaw of the lefties that
for what you may agree with them on the
parts where Bernie will talk about crony
capitalism or that sort of stuff that
you don't like or the big money in
politics and all that that the answer is
always exactly what the problem is his
answer is always given more money his
answer is always give it more power
where a more libertarian answer your
answer I think something closer to my
answer would be well you starve the
freakin beast
you just starve it till it has no more
power no I think their central problem
is their obsession with equality at any
cost and because even if they weren't
involved in government they're still
gonna be pushing this kind of bizarre
equality agenda which has death deathly
consequences think what did you see I
was just on Tucker Carlson because
Elizabeth Warren well it's a 50
percent female and non-binary cabinet
well which is very important I would
imagine but there's even there's more
nefarious consequences you had in
Florida with that school shooting
basically this kid was telling them that
I'm going to shoot up the school and
they said well same kids don't do this
we're gonna put you in special ed and
then you forget I forgot Nikolas screws
his name and Andrew [ __ ] his dad
wrote a book about this because his
daughter was killed so then they don't
want to report him because then you have
the school to Prison Pipeline they want
to have the good statistics and
eventually what the logic of the left is
if one person has a problem everyone has
to have that problem
that's equality and he came and true
this word he shot up that school and
it's like we all saw this coming but
because you are obsessed with this idea
that everyone has to be treated the same
or treated fairly you know it leads to
death it leads to the meat grinder so
even though you like this idea of the
internal fighting do you think like aoc
has been making a point which again this
is someone who I disagree without most
of the stuff but I think she does get
one every now and again which is she's
basically been saying why am I in the
same party as Joe Biden that does make
sense to me these people have really
nothing no matter how woke Biden tries
to become now you know he's trying at
this little end stage which is sort of
sad but it's like they shouldn't be in
the same party should they well I mean
America is very unique because most of
the European countries have like
parliamentary systems where they have
like nine parties like in Iceland right
now there's a party that's just
dedicated to people with disabilities
and they have seats in the parliament so
they get that specific and issue-driven
yeah the fact that we only which has its
own set of problems of course it does
and it's hard to form coalition's and so
on the fact that we only have two
parties with the country that's what 350
million and those are supposed to cover
everyone's views this is an example of
why politics is landline technology for
a post cellphone world that we go back
in the 80s you know every terrible
comedian would joke about all this coke
and now there's Diet Coke and there's
cherry coke what's next caffeine free
cherry Diet Coke yeah you could have
that and that's not a problem but why do
I have to have two choices and those
choices are Coke or Pepsi when I would
prefer not to drink soda at all and that
is not an option and it's it's getting
hard and Europe we're seeing is very
heavily the fragmentation it's getting
very very hard to form coalition's at
51% and that's wonderful yeah because
Israel's had what 17 elections so it's
it's a very healthy thing that people
are regarding the two parties as not
being representative of them and their
views so for a guy that's obviously not
on the left that doesn't you know
particularly subscribe to those ideas
what would a sane left look like cuz I I
think maybe you would want some level of
saying left right I think there's a lot
of saying left I think you work so what
is the same that all it takes is being
read pilled recognize it because here's
why I can talk to the Bernie people
here's why I can talk to the Tulsi
people if I ever found this Hawaii
imaginary place yeah here's why I could
tell the time people are listening right
now ya know converting me because once
you realize that we are being
manipulated lied to and tried to be
controlled and we're also told that
anyone who says these things is a
conspiracy theorist so right away not to
listen to him you know even though the
Weinstein conspiracy has been
demonstrated the epstein conspiracy has
been demonstrated the Constitution was
written as a conspiracy they met in
secret and you know basically throughout
the law and said we're just going to
overthrow the government
all these things were conspiracies once
you realize this then you could have an
honest conversation I have not had that
Bernie experience that you had but
you're a more higher profile than I am
but that is a starting point where it's
like let's talk honestly instead of
having these two minute hates trying to
you know destroy people on a personal
level which maybe they do I don't
understand again I'm not familiar with
the Bernie crowd but that is the
starting point of a stain left because
there's like then what is it actually
like what are the ideas I was just going
to say nope none no one I know would
have a problem with the lefty who says I
believe in a welfare state I don't want
to live in a country where people
starving in the street I don't think
someone should be bankrupt because they
got cancer and I want my kids even if
they're destitute to be able have a
decent quality of education that's the
same lefty yeah and I don't think any
well I'd say that's an old-school
liberal basically right once Malu it
wants a little more government than a
nan cat wants sure but it's to help
people right the libertarian people
would say well you're actually not
helping them you're any sure but that's
not no that's an easy conversation
yeah that's very different from you know
this kind of fundamentalist faith where
overnight we have to care not only about
trans people but specifically
transgender bathrooms not any other
transition this is the one trans issue
and if you don't care about this one
specific sub issue of this greater issue
you can be read out of polite society
that is coming from a place of
domination and control not a place of
empathy and sympathy it's a really great
way of looking at it because remember
when that whole transgender bathroom
thing happened in was that in North
Carolina and then suddenly the NBA said
we're not gonna have the all-star game
here and Obama said we're gonna cut
funds to the state and all of those
things and it's like guys we're have
we're trying to have some level of a
decent conversation and you guys have
now taken this too we're literally
talking about the power of the federal
government over transgender bathrooms
yeah and that's the dangerous part here
for most people I think yeah I think
people for a long time the corporate
press has been very good at using
persuasion and now that the you know
animus toward them is at all-time highs
and hopefully will keep escalating their
masks is dropping and they're
demonstrating they're perfectly
comfortable using their be move which is
force if necessary do you think they
think they're getting away with it so a
great example of this would be just what
happened to Joe Rogan in the last little
bit so Rogen basically endorsed Bernie
he did it but he put not even quiet
right for him he's right so he was so
everyone was saying it was an
endorsement but it was basically like I
like the guy he's been consistent over
the years something like that and CNN
from CNN's Maine verified Twitter
account literally said something to the
effect of Bernie Sanders under heat
because he takes the endorsement of
homophobic racist Islamophobic comedian
Joe Rogan and it's like yeah you don't
have to love Rogen and I get it he's
been cluded on scary charts that you and
I have been included on you know these
charts they're out there sometimes they
put you know little line next to each
other and then it's like oh my god but
that's not a conspiracy theory right
that's not yeah you're right exactly
exactly and and then yeah all right well
put that aside for a sec but when you
see that it's like whoo they're they got
almost nothing left but this is the
tactic of there's that I've called out I
have a master threat on Twitter it's
called as an aside so for example if I
was describing you as
an objective or even bias let suppose
have a biased journalist and I don't
like you yeah I would still say Dave
Rubin comma who is a popular podcaster
comma said blah blah blah right that's
an accurate framing yeah their first
sentence is always to ascribe the most
nefarious framing possible to this
person right so the reader right well
that Reena right away knows this is
someone to avoid Joe Rogan comma who has
a history of making homophobic and
racist jokes comma if you had to
describe Joe Rogan look at his Wikipedia
that's not what he's known as mm a
comedian podcaster no one would define
him that way unless you are telling and
training your audience what to think
it's completely disingenuous and that's
the difference we've been having a bias
and having an agenda if it was a bias
they said Joe Rogan popular podcast
however he's gotten controversy for this
you show both sides that's not what
they're doing they're telling you front
and center this person is the enemy and
you should shun him and what's beautiful
is look who the corporate press has
needlessly ain't alienated through their
Shiki Nuri Rogan fans
tulsi fans Bernie fans Andrew yang fans
Trump fans Kobe fans Don Imus fans it's
amazing they can't help themselves
because again when you have a
fundamentalist faith you are certain
that you're on the side of the Angels
that is a tough one to fight fine mess
for us it's easy because they're
delusional not touch with reality so as
I mean if you if there's an asymmetry
between truths and lies right if I tell
you a hundred truths and one lie you're
gonna look at me as a liar if I kill one
person and never kill anyone else I'm
still a murderer right so if I'm
presenting myself as an objective news
organization and I'm caught once twice
twelve times the average person who
doesn't have any political persuasion
one or another will not look at me as
trustworthy and once Trust is lost it is
almost impossible to be regained so with
that in mind let's talk about this clip
that went viral the CNN yes it's Don
Lemon who's there you know main anchor
done Don used to be a friend of mine he
was on this show I'm not here to throw
the guy under the bus Don Lemon , who
used to be a yeah exactly who must be on
a chart with dave rubin
yeah and it was Rick Wilson who is
is he a Republican strategist ibly yes
supposedly right I mean thinks he said
that's what it says under his name and
the other person was read I forget his
name it and I'm gonna sound racist if I
try all right so we were and some other
guy but it's three of them they've got
their heads in boxes on CNN and can you
just describe what happened and and then
the reaction well it's such a perfect
example of all there was a lot to unpack
in this clip so Rick Wilson was making
the joke that Trump is so dumb that he
couldn't find Ukraine on a map right
this is you know 101 and Don lemons
original there's this there's this
mental there's this condition called
Angelman syndrome and when kids have it
they can't help but laugh all the time
and it's kind of disturbing because
they'll be in their crib just cracking
up and he just loses it as if it's the
funniest thing he's ever heard and I'm
like this is first grade playground
stuff it's not clever and they start
going off on how all these Trump voters
look oh you guys are elitist with your
geography and your lines on the map it
all felt extremely produced like do you
think that was spontaneous I think was
very spontaneous really thing off each
other and here's my point there's
something I talk about the book called
mid wits and you can tell me why you
think it's not that you'd not
spontaneous because the way they were
riffing off each other these people
don't riff off each other
well like now you see when you see lemon
and Cuomo do it it's horrible it's so
stilted you can tell these people don't
really like each other
they have this awkward minute between
their shows when they do it and also I
know a lot of these people like you know
a lot of people like the way they are
and their ability to be human on camera
it's not like this it literally it's not
like this yeah we're doing right now
where it's like we have cameras on us
but we're acting basically the same you
know there's always like you turn the
camera on what's that what's that theory
you know there's that there's a name for
that theory when you turn the camera on
oh I don't know I can't remember what
it's called but but we're basically
acting like ourselves and there's
nothing suddenly that this camera goes
off that I'm gonna add our interaction
would be wildly different right I got to
dinner a couple weeks ago is this right
as I said it being the show this is how
I dress this is exactly what you were
wearing you were wearing the tulsi luck
that tell see a prayer I keep forgetting
but so it struck me as the level that
Don was laughing did not strike me as
uncontrollable after he struck me as
uncontrollable
fake laughter interesting and the way
that they were all bouncing back and
forth was like they had planned this
like they need something to go viral
like I don't know you you might be right
and maybe it's somewhere in between what
we're both saying both theories are so
stupid
it's hard to figure out what works in
reality right I'm hearing what you're
saying and it's completely plausible
they sat down and did like the worst
improv class in history but there's a
couple of things in that clip that I
thought are very cogent there's this
concept called mid wits that is I
mentioned my book which is about people
who are marginally intelligent right
when you're barely smarter than average
but you have debt are desperate to
demonstrate your brilliance right
because there's very few chances where
you going to be the smart one if you're
six-foot you are tall you're above
average but when are you going to be the
tall guy never so to think that being
able to find Ukraine who everyone who's
played risk can fought it can be found
on a map as a sign of your brilliance
speaks to your intelligence and the
other point is Jim go the the writer who
wrote the redneck manifesto he made the
point that every single stereotype
that was applied in the past toward poor
low status blacks was overnight by these
same people applied to poor low status
white hmm you go back and watch that
clip and those accents they they do in
those voices all of those lawns on that
book-learnin they are one second what
they're 60 years away from saying the N
word about the same kind of population
it's it's the status thing and racism
and classism have always been very
hand-in-hand in this country so then
what is going on in their minds in a
segment like that do they honestly think
that they are helping whatever the cause
like this is what I think I think now
they are in retreat I think they get a
lot of heat on social media where people
call them out on their malfeasance and
depravity and they're getting defensive
and now they are being sarcastic because
sarcasm is often a sign of cognitive
dissident dissonance where your brain
has to contradict your ideas and can't
reconcile them so for them the idea that
maybe I always tweeted this at these
people I go have you ever wondered if
maybe you're one of the bad guys
the idea that we're not better than
everyone else that we're not
particularly bright it's true but it's
very disturbing to their self-image
because
I'm on CNN I'm on a panel clearly I'm
brilliant and no Anna Tavares on those
peppers
she's a William Howard Taft she's also
called me racist on Twitter so you know
Navarro , yeah yeah who's called de
bruin racist comma who sat down with
Michael malleus Khan who was you know
yeah tulsi gabbard appropriated that
yeah okay it reminds me of something
that happened to be about a year ago a
good friend of mine who I went to I grew
up with I went to college with we both
studied political science together we've
been friends for you know our whole
lives you know forty some odd years he's
a huge lefty now obviously we diverged
politically but we went out for a drink
and we sort of got into it and he was
getting very heated and I just kept
trying to get out of polity and I'm sure
you've been in a million of these where
you just you try to let it go and
there's something that's beyond politics
and I was trying to talk about his kids
and everything else going on and he we
couldn't get there and I finally said to
him I said do you think that I believe
what I believe as much as you believe
what you believe and without pausing
with no hesitation he said no and I
thought and then yeah and this is a
really healing this is a really rare
moment for me it then it then really
escalated and I've never done this
before I swear to you I've never done
this before David rhew I've never done
this before
I threw money down I paid for the whole
thing the whole tab right there and I
walked out I've never done anything like
that before and it's so counter to right
everything you know about me but I
thought that moment right there like you
have to sit in that now like I'm not
attacking your motives but you actually
believe that I can't believe what I
purport what's amazing is there is a
continuum and there's lots of people who
would blurt that that out and as soon as
they heard themselves say it they'd be
like whoa whoa okay I've gone down the
wrong path and there's but the thing is
they've been so trained especially the
last few years if you asked one of these
types is it possible that Trump is just
crappy mediocre tabouli McKinley is that
okay with you and they're not going to
really have an answer because it's very
important that he is the worst president
who's ever lived although by there's
very few metrics where you can make that
argument are you finding that there is
an undercurrent of support for Trump now
that did not exist last time that
suddenly this thing has gone so bananas
everything we've been talking about for
this half-hour that now there's people
that would have never considered voting
for Trump the first time that basically
still see the wheels on the machines
still see some level of pride in America
still see paychecks that are working an
unemployment that's low in black
unemployment that's low and Hispanic on
implement that's low and they like
getting rid of some of the regulation
and all of those things that were not in
extra Wars and he's trying to get us out
of Afghanistan and everything else that
suddenly people that could would have
been completely in opposition to Trump
last time I think I'm not up there I
think a lot of them are just going to be
happy to stay home they're gonna be like
look I can't bring myself to vote for
this guy he's you know we can think of
all the names but I'm not going to
endorse this especially if Biden is the
nominee I gave Biden money because when
he went in front of these coal miners I
know how to shovel coal you can learn
how to program a computer I'm like I
need a year of this he literally did the
learn to code me I mean for those of my
people that but but for people that know
about this meme this was a meme that
when what was it was a BuzzFeed when
BuzzFeed was gonna yes and they laid off
a lot of journalists yeah and and
they're all boo-hooing and then all the
trolls in the coach I used the word
trolls and the good sense yeah added
them a hashtag learn to code yeah and
people got kicked off with Twitter
meaning learn how to do something
productive right that of being a
BuzzFeed and bright and Biden actually
brought it to life but he also brought
to life and it's an audience where it's
not accurate right it is if you know how
to write for BuzzFeed you could probably
have the technical skills to learn how
to code on a basic level right if you're
a coal miner that does not mean you know
how to use a computer well this is not
and by the way if you're computer
programmer
you can't mine coal I there these do not
transition very easily so and I think it
was comfortably smug who tweeted out
that you do know if there's the debates
Trump is gonna bring that stripper and
put her in the front row and ask Joe if
he's met his granddaughter and it's
going to be just complete chaos so III
hope he's the nominee very desperately
but watching him is sort of depressing
right I know so I know this is where you
wouldn't it's depressing in that for for
someone that's a little more old-school
politics are not on the fringe of the
new right yeah but for someone that like
you know I want the system to some
how function even though I always tell
you it's like I love all the
intellectual adventures I go on with you
I really do but for someone that wants
like some thing to kind of hold that was
somewhat centrist and we could have an
interest that's Biden know but he can't
do it anymore it seems like he can't do
it which is why he's telling these guys
to code it's why he's saying you can
pick your gender depending on which jail
you want to go to he said that yeah at
the Equality forum someone said it's not
what birth sex you are it's what you
identify it you have an awful lot of
male rapists in women's prisons he
literally said that he was brought in as
the same guy and he can't be sane but I
think that gets to your point that this
thing just eats through everything
yeah yeah right and I he again he
doesn't have that space within his party
I can't believe he said that about the
jails I mean this is hilarious but I am
NOT making it up how are you how are you
not how is this depressing to you this
is glorious I don't I can't just telling
my guys right now we're gonna play the
clip right now in prison the
determination should be that your sexual
identity is defined by what you say it
is not what in fact the prison says it
is and in that case you should be
entitled also to OGB whining anyway you
don't notice that question because not
likely to either I guess
well there you go malice that's the man
that you want to be the Democratic
candidate for president desperately one
of the things that this speaks to is one
of the best aspects of conservatism
which is asking questions like what do
you when you're advocating for a program
what do you do with the people who will
use this program in bad faith or this
law in bad faith and very often people
on the Left don't have an answer or
they'll hand wave it away like oh there
won't be that many cases well that don't
we that many cases again is Nicholas
Cruz in Florida shooting up a school
it's that outlier that both moves
culture and also is the destroyer and
that is who we should be concerned about
what else you tracking right now what
else is on your mind out of the that's
unearthed I've been in the bottom of the
Internet and I well I've been so I've
been engaging in like psyops with a lot
of these types so for example when
you're working on a campaign you're
going to have tunnel vision bunk you're
gonna you're living in a bunker right so
when there's an Arctic
that comes out in the New York Times
everyone the campaign is freaking out
how is this going to play how the other
campaigns you kind of have like Plato's
cave very limited information so what I
do is I have a bigger Twitter following
than many of these campaign managers for
these candidates so instead people tweet
like nasty things at them that'll
strengthen their resolve if you're
saying Oh warrants this and that it's
like yeah I'm fighting for her against
you so I will be like hey at Roger Lau
latest polls came out from Iowa five of
the six candidates have solidified their
support only Warren has lost support how
depressed are you at the campaign on a
scale of one to Anthony Bourdain and
then that gets retweeted and you know
it's filling up his notifications yeah
and he's already having a bad day and
now he's gonna be freaking out even more
hopefully so your instead of killing
them with attacks it's not quite
kindness you're killing you're killing
you're killing them with sarcasm based
on sarcasm this is your question I mean
it other than I'm giving the devil on
their left shoulder steroids and being
like more insecurity more fear more
freaking out and just ginning up that
kind of I mean I can't imagine working a
campaign is in a state of constant
stress and and panic and you're putting
out fires all the time so let's add some
gasoline and watch it burn how concerned
you that the at the social media level
and the big tech level that the game has
been so rigged and manipulated already
that we have no idea what's going on you
know I keep mentioning this thing about
shadow banning is now in Twitter's Terms
of Service okay they can literally
throttle accounts we've we've known sure
that they've been doing it forever but
now they're telling us they're doing it
as of January 1st and we all just keep
playing the game as if the game is not
being read but the game is always going
to be rigged I mean when you have your
enemies to expect them to play fair is
extremely naive this is my Soviet
mindset talking we did have a president
who tweeted his way into the White House
and I think what people don't appreciate
is the existential angst it causes
someone who works at a social media
company to see their product or their
program being from their perspective
subverted by those who they despise to
further their agenda this must cause
them a lot of grief but doesn't it also
cause them to you know tighten those
pickets and make sure that as we get
closer to the election that
no malice isn't gonna be heard as much
or Trump's not gonna be heard as much or
Rubin or anybody else I'm sure I mean
the thing we all pretend that that's not
really it like that would be the thing
that we would all be relentlessly
talking about right if I mean really
were trying to change something here I
think they are losing tools in their
toolbox and I think I mean you know
camel Harris you know was calling for
Trump to be banned from Twitter remember
this yeah and she got pushed back even
from the left and when she lost her
campaign I did a ham tasting on my
livestream and we tried you know
different kinds of hams from all over
the world because the pig was finally
roasted so I think they are going to try
different tactics but because they're
being called out on their tactics
instead of being called out on the
issues this is why they are freaking out
it used to be they would say Dave Rubin
is a racist and you would spend months
being them no I'm not no I'm not now
it's Dave Rubin saying look at their
technique of calling me Rogen everybody
else a racist as a means of preemptively
dismissing them so by you calling out
their technique it loses almost all its
efficacy you know it's funny because
like three years ago let's say when
daily beast or mother jones or any of
these awful things these these gee what
do you call it you call them jihadist
jihadis without the testosteron yes
whenever they were doing then they would
call me all these things you know I'd
fight back and then you know I could
occasionally get them to change one line
or whatever but then they wouldn't they
wouldn't actually retweet the thing they
would just change it and nobody's seen
it and whatever it's out there it's out
there for them right stealth edit so
then Wikipedia can grab from it and
write and the rest of it but it used to
really upset me obviously when I first
you know like anyone that starts getting
that heat it yeah it's hot at first and
in a weird way now because I've book
coming out in April and I know what that
is gonna cause that that microscope to
look at me or you know really fine-tune
on me is that I'm glad that I went
through it now yeah do you find that too
that you've been through a lot of the
the hits on this stuff and it's like
that actually makes you stronger now oh
and especially it makes my audience
stronger cuz they love it because yeah
because there's it's like a greatest
hits album right so it's xenophobic
racist homophobic blah blah I'm from
Brooklyn I'm an immigrant yeah I mean so
when they state when I went
during George Soros Oh can you talk yeah
talk about this this is a this was this
is exactly why I think you're such a
great thinker truly what what this whole
Soros thing oh it was beautiful so some
guy from the Atlantic and I'm not trying
to be dismissive about genuinely don't
remember his name
yeah glad looks pretty terrible these
they've been but Dave they say this is
where they're terrible since Woodrow
Wilson no I mean even before in the
nation I mean these people were the ones
agitating for World War one I mean you
have to go back so they there is Rudy
Giuliani made a comment that he's more
Jewish than George Soros now in any
other context if you were talking to
Jewish people and said someone can be
culturally Jewish without actually
having Jewish ethnicity as opposed to
someone could have Jewish ethnicity and
basically be a total [ __ ]
right this is not controversial this is
very well known and everywhere everyone
knows this Obama kept saying he was the
first Jewish president this is very
known we're both Jewish we know people
who are super Jewish and then people who
were basically lost and the people who
are adopted Jews basically yeah I would
like the culture and the guy from the
Atlantic was like ah in the world of
Trump someone can be less Jewish
somebody else and he sang this about a
literal Holocaust survivor right
referring to Soros yeah but what was
amazing is in the same way it's Dave
Rubin comma secret Klansmen and
homophobe comma it's George Soros comma
literal Holocaust survivor now I always
say the corporate press is factual but
not truthful
it is factual that George Soros survived
the Holocaust he was Jewish he was in
Hungary I believe he was under Nazi
occupation his life was in danger
however the ik and in any other context
people would understand argue the
experience of Jews who fled Germany and
got to America is not the same as the
experience of Jews who survived occupied
territory is not the same as a Jew who
escaped the camps or survived the camps
these are three they're all Holocaust
survivors these to see these are
separate things but by using that term
they are trying to say George Soros yeah
multinational billionaire is beyond
criticism specifically because of the
Holocaust and they came at me blah blah
blah and I'm like look I was born in
Ukraine
my family survived the Nazis and the
commies I went to yeshiva
you're not I've been circumcised three
times you're not gonna outdo me that's
pretty excessive so some guy came at me
and he's like oh you know my grandfather
died in the Holocaust family history
doesn't matter sometimes you could just
be a jerk and I go I paused this is one
the few times I paused or II tweeted I
go I was wondering who died and made you
an insufferable prick but now I guess we
know because you are not going to waive
your grandfather's ashes at me to win
some Twitter beef to defend George Soros
and I said the Atlanta guy said if you
want to make George Soros out to be some
sort of modern-day and frank I can't
stop you but this is what they do all
the time it was really funny especially
camel-hair it's a great example because
they couldn't figure out a criticism of
her was racist or sexist right so
whatever the the there's only like ten
words to use and once you say I'm not
even having this talking with you they
have no power but it isn't it the irony
that it's also the people that find
bigotry everywhere can't find it when
it's actually right there oh sure this
happens constantly I mean Soros is such
a great example it's the guys given
hundreds of millions of dollars if not
billions of dollars to all these NGOs
that basically are just trying to
destroy Israel this is not so he may be
Jewish but is he a friend of the Jews or
whatever that even means like but here's
the thing any logical explanation even
if he literally was taken out of
Auschwitz and thankfully he wasn't you
know that he had it much easier
certainly I don't wish that on anybody
almost the idea that a billionaire is
beyond beyond reproach yeah I mean this
is the number one person Koch brothers
Soros Sheldon Adelson these are the
number one people Tom Steyer who should
be subject to scrutiny because they're
using their wealth to influence the
political process that's the number one
person that you want to look at with
skepticism so to have them run
interference for Soros in the name of
the Holocaust was so off-putting me and
I was very glad that I'm like I'm not
backing down from these efforts and like
not for one second and I didn't yeah it
was great yeah you didn't what do you
make of the the billionaire crew so the
Bloomberg steyr crew that desperately
want in on the DNC now or what's
happening with the Dems and it's like
you guys do you have any idea even if
you could buy the nomination
the radical activists will do to you at
the end Tom Steyer what a loser I mean
you're gonna be a billionaire and he's
just bet he's he stands there with
Bernie like please don't throw me in the
pit of Sarlacc please don't throw me in
the pit estar like you know he we had
the Republicans we had back in the day
Maurice afer Maury Taylor yeah he was
here and I think in 96 or something he
was some kind of big businessman
it is watching Tom Steyer talk and it's
like it's very cute because when you
reach a certain amount of money right my
understanding is you will have people
who will tell you what you want to hear
in order to be your consultant
so they sat down with him like yeah yeah
Trump did it why can't you
so I think it's fun to watch him but I
don't think he's going where Bloomberg
what do you make of the way he kisses
the ass of the socialist like doesn't it
just strike you as the most pathetic no
I think this is the guy who there's a
lot of these types they made it on Wall
Street but they want to be with who they
perceive to be the cool kids and now
he's on stage with Bernie and I think
he's genuinely excited oh it strikes me
as so pathetic I don't even think I
don't know I don't think you're wrong
necessarily that just rude but the idea
that this guy Bernie who really has so
many counter ideas to what allowed steyr
to become a billionaire and he just gets
up there and he's like a little yipping
dog around Bernie and Bernie's always
like shoo shoo unless it just seems so
pathetic listen when Telsey followed me
on twitter there may have been shrieking
and running it back and forth in my home
yes I'm not in fashion dr. Josh Tom
Steyer to be excited to be debating
Bernie what do you think Bloomberg fits
into this whole thing because every
freaking ad on YouTube right now it's a
Bloomberg ad I mean this guy is throwing
every dime but he's got a track record
yeah like of all of them he actually has
a great track record to run for
president and is this amazing he's got
was worth 50 billion and he's only
spending like 1 billion it's like what
do you need the other like 26 billion
for so does he strike you then as when I
asked you before well what does the the
sane left look like or if they can get
out of this thing what does that
moderate Democrat look like that seems
to be far more Bloomberg at this point
then than Biden I wouldn't say that
because I think Bloomberg is really a
zealot when it comes to his biggest
issue which is the guns and I'll get the
sodas well no that's not he doesn't talk
about that anymore you know
he really wants the gun so he tested it
he tested the gun thing with the soda
thing yeah yeah I guess that's one way
of looking at it yeah
so when it comes to that like in their
social socio sociology the gun is a
heretic elect and can never be treated
as positive or even neutral it has to be
kind of like cursed and you show it in a
positive light
whenever you possible so he's really
drank the flavor aid on that one and
that's what makes him quite dangerous
okay but if you remove the gun one and I
completely hear you on this I mean even
just the there was the shooting at the
church and basically Bloomberg was
condemning the guy that the shooter the
thing is if you remove the gun thing
he's not running you see is the the
problem with these types is the thing
that the one issue that is the problem
is the one issue they care about that
would be like steyr and climate change
right because he just gets up there and
right yeah that's his only issue the
only thing that matters so like when
Elizabeth Warren starts talking about
like you know transgender right she
doesn't care about that this is
something she did you know H how was she
70 something you don't age 70 suddenly
realized that you want reparations
that's not a thing this is something
she's like alright I got a I think she
saw in 2016 two very venal people get
the nomination and she's like alright
this is a politics is I'm gonna have to
sell my soul and basically out Trump ran
out Hillary both of them and she's doing
a piss-poor job of it do you sense that
the train left the station on
reparations even like they were talking
about it a couple months ago at the
early debates and even now it's not
being talked about almost as if enough
people were like no no III mean they
just have it's insane because the base
but they don't need the logic behind it
they just if they do they just have the
issue right though it's not like the
money or the numbers would have had to
have mattered sure but I think also a
lot of people in the black community
realized that the Democratic Party often
takes them for granted I think that
often what that was trying to be a wedge
to get black voters who were very Pro
Obama obviously who are going to be for
Biden to pull them away from him because
he's not I don't think for reparations
or at least yet and I think it was kind
of a lead balloon because I agree with
you like when you have you know even the
center-left hearing this and being like
you're what are you talking about this
is not even practicable even if you want
it to happen yeah that's when they pull
back a little bit
it's never good in a society when you're
gonna be judged and condemned by your
father's sins right
we're not even your father your
grandfather's grandfather grandpa it
nothing good gonna yep all right I mean
a certain point it's just basically like
we're gonna it oh it's almost explicitly
we're gonna take money from them whoever
them happens to be and give the money to
us and then we're gonna find some ex
post facto reason why this isn't just
necessary but the moral thing to do this
is as night follows day you're feeling
pretty good about things I can tell I am
there's one graph that I want to reach
and if you talk about this constantly on
social media and my work it's people who
are black pilled black Pelt is the idea
that all ha all hope all hope is lost
and I think things are so exciting
online
it's so exciting our culture and things
are so beautiful and we can I could use
a curse you can we have a [ __ ] poster as
president you just asked me if you could
say [ __ ] poster well now I'm gonna lead
up to the n-word oh um we have a [ __ ]
poster as president it is so it's
everyday you wake up you're like how is
this real yeah and when you have the
left now understanding the nature of the
corporate press and becoming red pill
and like I welcome them with full love
in my heart and open arms like join us
like they're the enemy you're like me
and you are not the enemy we are we
might disagree but we're not each
other's enemies is that also part of it
I think that so I'm with you I think
there's something so hopeful right now
I've been talking about how there's so
much fertile ground for ideas there's so
many interesting people popping up all
over the place I didn't know who you
were
two years ago like there's so many I can
say whose name come on you must know me
I was lalala but yes there's so much
good and we and yes there's a part of
our brain I suppose that gets us focused
on the fighting and the negative and or
whatever that is even though I know you
think the fighting is good never but the
other part of this is the people that
are most sort of interested in right now
online are the people that are not
purely obsessed with this so like
there's like a certain crew that just
even that I think are smart politically
but like they just tweet politics every
[ __ ] day over and over and over and
it's so boring and painful and then
there's this other crew and I try to
this you know like I got my dogs in her
last days and I post about her a lot and
I try to post about food that I'm
cooking and other than funny and silly
things and things that you're doing and
it's like I
I think people want to see more complete
people some you know I think there's
such a move on line about
self-empowerment and making something of
your life I certainly have been talking
about mental health a lot more but my
social media and it's so rewarding when
you're young to be told if you want to
do it do it like maybe you won't be as
successful a podcaster as they Reuben
right but you can be somewhat successful
and even if you fail you're still you
still have to do it but you're also
fighting for something that matters to
you and that failure is going to be very
rewarding and you and I have both failed
on many things over the past and you
keep fighting keep fighting keep
fighting so that the fact that there's
so many opportunities to make something
yourself be self actualized it's such a
wonderful time to be alive and I feel so
sad for people who don't I'm saying you
don't have to be the best person on
earth but you have it in your power to
be a better person than you are now and
when you put in those terms like yeah
it's just that simple
man you channel it a little Jordan
Peterson over there what oh is that what
he talks about I mean it's a lot well
it's those twelve rules are to live the
best life you can I mean you're
traveling a little line ran there - I
mean you're channeling just this idea
it's your life get moving I was I'm an
immigrant so the fact that I am in a
position where I can be on this show
shirtless running my mouth having you
wearing underwear right to mix having
the time of my life and having people
who have day jobs who can't do this
crazy stuff enjoy it and being able to
pay my rent is so exciting and and to be
able to tell people look you know
there's so much out there for you to
enjoy it's it's it's and that's what the
left doesn't give them the left you
cannot be this depressed angry and
anxious for four years it's just not
cyclize like a healthy so even if Trump
is Hitler fine find your bliss within
this dystopian America that you perceive
us to be what
that movie life is beautiful that was it
right well I haven't seen that movie but
I see I mean they were in they were in a
concentration camp but the father
basically kept tricking I think it was
the daughter that you know that life is
beautiful despite everything I will you
gotta find something I will always be
Ricki with the plastic bag in American
Beauty and it makes me so sad to watch
so many people it's because of the
mentality is well I've tried nothing and
it hasn't worked we're going to give up
just try something it something is out
there for you yeah and that's what's so
cool about everything that we have right
now all of the technology you can do I
mean that's the number one question I
get I go to colleges and people like I
want to do what you do and I'm like do
it I mean there is literally what's the
best advice Dave do it yeah put some
stuff out there don't worry about view
counts don't try to just be there to
destroy everybody build something cool I
always have to build something cool so
that I am forced to put you on the show
yeah force my hand don't don't ask me
when you have 10 followers in your you
know make it so that one day it's like
dave has to have this guy on the show
right and and give people something of
value be earnest sarcasm and this
sneering is very very weak and cheap and
be clean here's the other advice and I'm
sure you're gonna agree I tell people
don't strive to excellence especially
when you're young you're not going able
do it
strive to competence if you are
competent if I can rely on you you are
at the 80th percentile and that is
within your means yeah and that's
actually a counter in many ways to what
people are being told we're sorry you're
just outsourcing everything all the time
and it's not your nothing's your fault
you shouldn't really work that hard and
they'll and they'll take care of you and
it's like we are given the the counter
message down yeah be reliable and that
you will have that guest on over and
over again I just I messaged you I'm
like hey maybe I'm too T one Tony one
horn here but it's just like I'm gonna
be in LA let's do a show you're like
sure well you know we tried several
other people everything fell through
said re cancel Paul CK I was like who is
that who's that guy that dresses like
tulsi or she dresses like him or say
alright this is what we're gonna do
yeah malice I have an idea yes it just
hit me while we're sitting here because
I find when you're having a good
conversation like this interesting ideas
pop up the week before the election I'm
gonna I want to do five shows that week
we usually do one or two shows a week I
want to do five shows Monday Tuesday
Wednesday Thursday Friday I want five
unique political people to be on that
weekend I'm gonna make two comments here
that I want you to be part of I want you
to be one of those people because I want
five people from completely different
walks of life and political persuasions
to just give me like what's happening
right now before the election so I have
to fill my eye with blood like Biden
yeah your eye has to actually explode
you have to announce that men should be
in women's prisons like the whole thing
so I want you as one of those shirts
that's number one and number two I want
to do a post-election blowout that night
I want you here if I have to fly in LA
whatever we have to do okay that's the
only way I will fly you here you're
gonna have to pay for your dress or
whatever else you're gonna be wearing
that dance but we will fly you here
we'll feed ya how about this do it fair
enough yeah absolutely done it was a
pleasure my friend and for more on the
hijinks of michael malice follow him on
twitter it's at michael malice if you're
looking for more honest and thoughtful
conversations about politics instead of
non-stop yelling check out our politics
playlist and if you want to watch full
interviews on a variety of topics watch
our full episode playlists all right
over here and to get notified of all
future videos be sure to subscribe and
click the notification bell